I mean for me, I feel like I haven't changed much.
Like my look apart from the only thing that's changed is the spikiness of my
hair. Over the years. You've calmed down.
You can tell the Gignac years by the younger,
I am like the more spikes in the hair. Yeah. There are,
you look at some of my first videos and I look like SaaS gay man and wondering,
right?
Like how did you decide on that hair style? Cause that's like, that's a look.
You've had since you were young or no, I think, I can't remember.
I just remember, because I have like hair that's really easy to be spiked up.
Right.
So I think ever since constitutes easy to spike up like light and
I mean like, could you spike up easily? If I, my hair, like,
if I cut it short, I put a bit of water in it and it just like immediately,
like naturally it's just like the anime character spice,
Asian hair has that to it. Cause like my hair is also like quite story.
So like if I put gel in it and it's just art for, I dunno, like yeah,
no, I get that. But like, then again, it's like,
just because your hair can do that doesn't mean you have to like.
What's that? Okay. Was it inspired by anime? What is he inspired?
He was inspired by.
So many hairstyles.
I could pull off and I had no idea what the I was doing with my hair.
Therefore look, it,
it was the hairstyle that took the least amount of effort to do.
Yeah.
That's not okay. It wasn't because like I said,
my hairstyle is just naturally spiky. So all I would need to do,
just put a bit of water, put a bit of gel and just go.
No, because it was done.
It naturally like naturally went to that shape.
Naturally.
Sonic the head just woke up and I was Sonic. Like what can I say? No,
because like I remember in some older videos, your hair is like,
so it looked like a wig. That's like, that's how perfect the spike was.
I was like, this man could pass off as like a sidekick.
It was like, you'd been watching too many, like David Bowie concerts.
I like that. I'm going to, I'm a mimic that basically that's what it looks like.
Yeah. I, I wasn't trying to mimic anything I had no, I just had like,
no idea what the. It.
Was like some guy who was like trying to bring back like the eighties.
Glamour, because it's like, whatever the Mr. Adam,
may you talk to you about that? It's so funny watching that and seeing God,
just like with like this teenage hat, it's really sad.
I feel bad. But like, obviously I was like, ah, it's funny now.
Like if you didn't know the context and you just saw the thumbnail,
it looks like those like angsty.
Yeah,
it is totally air con it. Hair.
It's like Sonic the hedgehog or you're talking about like,
you're talking about like occupy, like the most serious thing.
And you got like this Sonic hair. Know my child focus on it.
Yeah, because I'm just talking about, yeah. This guy just like killing me,
but bro, that hair that's, this man's hair has its own orbit.
Yes. Welcome to trash tastes where we are now.
Now we're trashing on each other's haircuts as, as good mates do what,
what are we doing? That's what constitutes as a mate, right? Like,
can you really call your mate a mate?
If they don't make fun of you after a haircut? Okay. Like, did you read,
did you,
what age did you reach where you actually like paid attention and gave a about
what you looked like? Because I was like really late.
The reason I looked like that was because I didn't really give, it gave,
give a about what I looked like until I got to like my first,
second year of uni, I was probably about the same.
Interest in dating. When you, uh, you know,
you didn't never want to like date ago in school?
No, I was on an all boys school. Of course. I love my boys.
[inaudible] I don't care what you look like. It's all right. Yeah, no. Yeah.
I guess maybe it's because I went to a boys school that not to say that I didn't
hang out with girls.
I would love to have gone to a boys school yet.
Even got the pressure of having to try and get across. Yeah.
I've got a girlfriend just because everyone else is getting one.
Yeah. I mean, you know, not to say that I didn't have any interest in dating,
but it's just like, it wasn't a priority.
But I was speed running them in school, man. I,
I never had one that lasted more than like two weeks.
Oh yeah. That was school relationships.
I had one that lost like three months and the boys were like,
you lost the three minutes. If you lost more, lots is a long time.
It's a long time. That's a, that's a dedicated relationship beyond a month.
It's like, okay. I am dedicated to re probably getting married.
You know what I mean? It's like one step away from marriage, right. Was like,
my life set already off.
I think I must have started paying attention to like how I looked at maybe.
Well, okay. I say how I looked basically like everything else was like,
what am I going to wear a school outfit? You know,
my mum still bought all my clothes. So like, yeah.
I'm not going to lie. I didn't start buying my own clothes until I moved out.
My mom was just like, yeah,
I got this nice t-shirt it was like some $5 t-shirt from target. And I was like,
yeah, that.
My mom still buys me clothes and sends them.
And it sucks that she's better taste than me.
That's weird. Hockey's mom buys me clothes, but my own mother doesn't anymore.
Remember us? We did a shoot like a, like a week ago.
I remember Joey had to borrow when you would one of your t-shirts and just
seeing Joey in one of your, like, t-shirts, I'm just like,
this is such a Conner shirt. Cause he was just like,
it was just like a plain t-shirt it's literally that, but a different color.
It's a plain, t-shirt in a drab color. And I'm just like, man, this,
this just screams color. It's a color that I would never buy it as a color.
That color would definitely.
It's taken. Okay. Let's give you another one. There's weird kind of things.
Right? Cause I've only like last year,
have I been open to the idea with owning shirts that have nothing but playing
color? Right. For some reason.
In my head is because you don't like logos. I hated.
Logos and prints. They drove me insane. I don't know.
For some reason it just looked cheap to me and always, and that's
normally that cheaper, these, these kids?
No, I guess it depends because some, some,
some of them can look very tacky and I feel like there's a fine line between
having a cool print and having like a cool piece of artwork that just looks
tacky on it.
Yeah. Like, you know, it's the whole concept of like simple as best sometimes,
you know,
let's like the whole reason why like all those like high brand shots and like
that. It's so simple. I mean, I think,
I think that's what changed my opinion of like fashion in general is I do,
I have started to be more open to spending a bit more money on clothes.
Cause at the end of the day, it's like, all right,
I'm wearing this for like how many months I'm going to be on camera as well,
especially. So like, I want to wear shirts. I mean today, I'll see, I'm still,
I've still got a little bit of the old [inaudible] recently. I've been like,
okay, I'm willing to spend like 80 bucks on a t-shirt,
which is unthinkable to me three years. Oh yeah. Bear in mind in university.
I used to get a prime Mark,
which if you don't know what prime markets is in the UK.
Prime, Mark's amazing. By the way, it's basically about on prime market.
I'm going to fight you on it.
Well, I mean, it's, you know, I,
I don't want to question how they make the shirts so cheap.
I'm sure there's some ethical question.
I remember I specifically bought eight t-shirts for 10 pounds,
which is like $15. Amazing.
And I love these shirts because they were all playing thing on them.
And I wore them for like two years straight. These shirts,
they were by the end of it.
For real, the prime Mark is like one of the best,
low budgets kind of clothing brands I've ever seen globally.
Honestly like the you can get for the price of prime Mark,
which I don't know where prime Mark's available internationally on it.
Cause I know it's in Europe. It's like,
if you want a budget place where you can just buy cheap clothes that don't read,
that don't look cheap.
Cause people said, Uniclo here is cheap. And we have Uniclo in the UK.
It's not Uniclo compared to prime. Mark is like,
Uniqlo is cheap for the quality that you get.
Like you'll pay a little bit extra for like a t-shirt at Uniqlo,
but that going to last, you like 10 plus years,
I bought a whole suit from prime Mark for like $40.
30 Pounds. The 30 pound set. Yeah, I did exactly the same for my.
My graduation. I wore a $40 suit and actually I hate to say it,
but it's like, it doesn't look that bad. It's not bad.
It's not bad. That's the thing. I mean,
prime Mark basically carried my university years.
But there's a big pot.
And a lot of people in the UK tend to also have the same mindset.
I think where the t-shirt should never cost more than 20, 30 pounds,
which I can understand because if you haven't got a lot of money spending that
much on one t-shirt is really quite a lot. It's quite a lot. But you know,
as I started to, uh, I think that's where my,
my hatred of print started is that I thought a lot of these prime Mark ones are
pretty and they often do look super tacky.
I don't really like the collaborations they have, like SpongeBob and.
And then all that, you know, they like, Oh yeah, we suck.
I think they're just starting to do anime as well. Which is weird.
I feel like was it last year where they did like a DBZ,
a one piece collaboration as well? Yeah. There's been a lot of stores like that,
like forever 21 as well before they went under,
like they did this like huge thing with anime.
So like every time I went to forever 21,
there was always like this entire section of anime. But when you look at it,
when, when you actually go over to it, it's just like, all right,
let's see what they have. It's all like Shayla moon. DragonBallZ.
All the basic. Gimme.
That. I don't want it done in like a creative way either. It's just like,
let's just slap the logo and the main character,
like doing anime clothes is really hard and we're probably going to have to like
call out like a bunch of, of you is my saying this.
But like the ones I hate the most are the ones where it's just like,
it's just a t-shirt with a wifi on it.
[inaudible] anatomy logo.
Like those kinds of clothes I call like anime convention, cloves. Cause it's,
it's, it's a t-shirt or clothes that I would only wear at an anime convention,
but there's no way I would wear pajamas.
The only time I'm wearing it is when I need to wear something in bed for someone
is probably someone watching this right now in like a Oslow t-shirt to be like,
Ooh.
And then like, I think as well,
going back to the whole cheap versus expensive stuff for clothes,
like it's only because I think, cause I moved to Japan,
I actually started seeing like some of the clothes that I like really like,
and it's like kind of expensive, but you're like, okay,
I am going to wear this a lot. Like when I paid like 350 bucks, for that,
that do you follow, uh, sorry. King Crimson jacket. Yeah.
Like when I bought that, that was the most expensive thing I'd ever bought,
like clothes wise. And I thought, Oh my God, this is insane.
But that's this peak insane $350 on a jacket. It's sexy.
Look on screen. It's sexy. But now that I've been wearing it,
I wear it like pretty much every day. Like I'm like, okay,
if I'm wearing it every day, you know,
and I get like maybe four or five years out of that.
That's right. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Cause I always thought that way with tech, right? Like to me, it's like,
don't buy a $20 headset by a hundred dollars at least because you're gonna get
your money's worth.
And I don't know why for some reason to be so long to have that with fashion.
And I think going back to the whole topic,
which is school and why I didn't give a is cause I didn't,
I just didn't care for clothes. I didn't really understand fashion at all.
I just looked like I,
there was always that one kid in your school who somehow always dressed amazing
to.
I didn't have that kid. I did not have that kid. I always, I dunno. I,
I had kind of like a similar view of fashion, which is just, I didn't get it.
I didn't understand anyone who would spend above like yeah. 20,
$20 or like $30 on the t-shirt.
I think my mum would like scoff. If my, if an outfit was over total $50,
she'd be like, look at, get a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that's the thing that it was that at least with me there was this light
because it was a boys school, but there was this whole,
I guess like stigma of dress world,
like that whole. Right. So I think people just I'm sure there were,
who actually did give a about fashion and did it, but they didn't want to,
because they'll probably worried about getting beaten up and like,
like I get that, you know, like it's, it's like, yes,
a fedora might seem quite fashionable, you know, in the comment. I,
but why would you wear that if you don't want to get bullied? You know,
like I like wearing doors. I think they look cool with the right outfit. But,
but the problem is a lot of, um, I agree with Joey, I feel like,
I feel like the frog, the big problem with fedoras is that the,
like the neck beard community
ruined that slim to hit the mustache.
You can't wear it because Hitler's ruined it.
It's the same thing with the fedora. You can't do it. Cause you're going,
everyone's like in the salad, that's the thing. But it's like,
but that's the problem I feel is that a lot of the reasons why fedora is just
commonly seen as that type of, you know, negative thing is because the,
the hat itself is fine. It's what you pair it with. Yeah.
Just makes it look like absolutely dog.
What you thought you're either going to look like a neck beard or you going to
look like a rip off Michael Jackson? No. In between, I mean,
I'd rather look like a rip off Michael Jackson than a neck beat. Right.
But like, but like I've seen, you can truly enjoy your life.
I've seen like fashion magazines of like dudes who like, you know,
wear a fedora or like a hat of some kind that's similar to a fedora in like a
really nice suit. Yeah.
We can match that with those like the most attractive men on the plane. Well,
that's what I'm saying. Right. And that's the,
that's the other problem is that no attractive man who waited for doors. Well,
I'm just saying, I'm just, I'm just preaching to the choir right now, but that,
you know, that's, I mean,
I'm not going to lie and pretend I know how fashion works, you know,
I'm not fashion.
[inaudible] I was like, let me teach you about fashion. I mean,
I feel like having that one kid in school who elevated the game really elevated
the elevated the game and ski was the benchmark. He was,
he was the trend system. He can be look bad. You know,
we need sends up with his jeans, with holes in them. I'm like,
how can we compete? I don't have holes in my jeans.